الحرب العالميه الثالثه باتت قريبا اعني
من خمس الى عشر سنوات في حال لم تتمكن
امريكا والصين من التعايش سويا هذا تحذير
اطلقه السياسي الامريكي الشهير هنري
كاسنجر في احدث مقابله له ما صحيفه
ستفعل اي شيء لابقاء الصين في حاله هبوط
وضع اما واشنطن فتصر على ان الصين تخطط
لتحل محل الولايات المتحده كقوه رائده في
العالم ويقول وزير الخارجيه السابق ان
مخاوفه تكمن في زياده حده التنافس بين
الصين وامريكا في مجال التفوق التكنولوجي
والاقتصادي خصوصا الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
سيكون له تاثير على الامن في الخمس سنوات
المقبله وقد يفوق خطره ما شاهده العالم
قبل ذلك في المقابل يرى كسنجر ان معرفه
الطرفين الصين وامريكا بالدمار المتبادل
والخطر الكامل من تقدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
قد يجنب العالم الحرب الثالثه داعيا
اياهما الى التعاون لتطوير اسلحه رادعه
للذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]